foreign
let's go to Washington DC where
everything is thought through and calm
and peaceful and talk to Christine
what's up Christine
hi thank you so much for having me on of
course what's up
okay so just a quick rundown I guess
um I'm 23 my boyfriend is 25. uh we've
been dating for a little over six months
now
um we're both pretty sure that this is
it going really well
I love it sure all right I've been
married for 21 years and my wife said
something the other day and I looked at
her and I was like I don't know you but
if you have it figured out in six months
good for you good for you all right so
so what's up we're giving the time we're
giving it time but um you're 22. 23 how
old are you I'm 23 23 it's a big
difference Jenna how does that how does
the Taylor Swift song go
that's what I was getting all confused
Christine all right so you're 23 he's 25
y'all have figured it out yeah you know
no problems ahead of us at all none okay
so what's up
um so it's going great family loves him
my friends love him and I know this like
issue doesn't have to do with him
but the issue I've been running into is
with my like group of girlfriends that
I've had since like childhood were like
best friends we do everything together
um have you know like keep in touch over
texts call I see them a lot
um
but in the last like two months two of
them have like separately and now like
together
um have kind of come up to me and said
that they think I'm spending too much
time with my boyfriend and that they
feel that I'm not prioritizing
prioritizing them as much as I should
all right keep going this is awesome
keep going okay
I don't even know any of your background
and I know that's not true and here's
why okay you you get to decide what your
relational priorities are
yeah
yeah and if if you have found the one
it just makes sense
yeah right yeah and I'll tell you
you will have some friends that are so
freaking excited for you
watching their friend be in love and be
gross and silly and I don't want to wait
like all Dawson's creaked out like
that's so like and awesome so great
and then you're gonna have a couple of
old friends
who the way they want their life to go
is now disrupted because somebody else
has found love and joy and different
relationship priorities
yeah and instead of looking in the
mirror they start throwing grenades
yeah and you're about to experience if
you're not already what I think was the
most heartbreaking thing that I didn't
know about I wasn't prepared for
actually the most heartbreaking thing I
wasn't prepared for was getting married
but second to that second to that was
like
I can't put into words the friendships I
had as an elementary school kid and as a
high school kid
yeah Brothers is all I can is the best I
mean I'm talking about guys who lay down
in traffic for me and vice versa yeah
yeah and I was unprepared for turning 23
and 25 and 28.
when one guy makes a decision like dude
I'm not hanging out with you if that's
how you're gonna roll
when yeah somebody gets in a bad car
wreck and everything shifts and one guy
moves away when I went to grad school
when somebody else gets fired from their
job somebody else gets married another
person gets married this one as a kid I
was unprepared for how lost I was when
my brother started Living their own
lives
I was really dumbfounded when my bestest
best friends in when I was in my 30s
when we all started having kids and it
was amazing at first and then one of
them turned out to be a Cub Scout dad
then the other one turned into be like a
little league Dad where he would like
doodle literally plays on his work pad
next to his phone and then I was like uh
let's go like on adventures dad and
they're like it's hot we're not going
out so I started realizing oh we're just
this is the part where we shift again
yeah and so you just have to do the hard
work with a few people that are gonna
root for you when things are great for
you
and that will hold you accountable now
if they were calling and saying hey we
think this guy's not a good guy
yeah and that's yeah that's
yeah when you're with him you are we see
our friend who we love sacrificing her
soul to be with this guy that's a
different thing because they've earned
the right to speak into that but if it's
just like you should be with us more
and they start singing Avril Lavigne
lyrics to you it's time just to as the
great Jason he said dust your shoulders
off and I know that sounds callous okay
so I threw a lot at you what do you
think
yeah I
yeah it's hard I know
um
I just I think my biggest thing is I
just I feel so guilty about it and it's
gotten to a point where like if I ever
choose hanging out like going out to
dinner with my boyfriend instead of
going out for drinks with my girlfriends
I I feel guilty about it even though I'm
I'm so joyful when I'm with him and like
at peace I don't know I I guess
how do I not feel so guilty about it
even though I know I'm I'm doing the
right thing I don't think that's that
just takes time I I would tell you
choose guilt over resentment every
single time
because if you choose to not hang out
with the person you want to be with and
the person that you have more fun with
and the person that yeah looks at you
and is like you're my girl forever like
all that like the back of the tailgate
country song stuff if you choose to not
be with him to go sit until the same
High School Stories and have the same
drinks and the same oh my gosh
you're gonna start to resent those women
yeah you're gonna hate it when they text
you yeah yeah and so choose guilt over
resentment you love them enough to not
let them drag you underwater into hate
yeah yeah the second thing is here's a
an important way I've shifted the way I
experience guilt in the world especially
when it comes to relationship stuff
and this is a hundred percent true
across the board
you can only show up for your friends if
you're whole
yeah if you're not okay hanging out with
your friends is you are not loving them
yeah right so you've got to be whole
and if you continue so when I say my
boundaries out loud the things that keep
me whole hey guys I don't drink anymore
hey guys I found out and it's
embarrassing that if I have gluten I
have a rocket diarrhea for like five
days and so like whatever it is you're
gonna have all your buddies they're good
they're supposed to make fun of you
that's their job like oh this guy can't
eat any food
um and that's fine that's that's just me
being a grown-up and thinking it's funny
and they've got their things
but there's always that one friend
that's like are you freaking kidding me
and they'll bring gluten stuff
everywhere and just shut up on you right
or every time you go to the oh you're
going to the gym oh my God and I just
want to shut up
at some point
they are choosing to not be in
relationship with me not the other way
around
yeah and that's heartbreaking
so the Heartbreak that you're
experiencing I want you to flip it
around you aren't feeling guilty
because you have found somebody that you
care about and you love and you actually
just like hanging out with him more than
the other people
which is a hundred percent normal by the
way
in that in that scenario you are the bad
guy and you're guilty for choosing A
over B
in the other scenario
your friends are choosing to be selfish
over watching their friend fall in love
and be have so much joy
they are choosing to not be in a
relationship with you so instead of
those feelings being guilt those
feelings are sadness and heartbreak
because you thought you thought those
girls loved you more than that
and they don't they love themselves
those women are about them not you
yeah and that is a heartbreak you got to
sit with that stings right
yeah but they are opting out of
relationship with you because they want
their picture more than they want your
joy and happiness
and I hate that for you yeah but I'm
also glad you filmed the one
it makes everything perfect
so it doesn't
has he farted in front of you yet
um
I don't know if he has oh you would know
that means y'all haven't got there yet
six months in So Perfect y'all aren't
even close but awesome but awesome
yeah
um
you're not broken there's not something
wrong with you
yeah I think that helps I it's just I I
guess it's just kind of new territory
for me and figuring out like I don't
know I just I just so enjoy being with
him and it feels weird that I prefer
that over my friends now and I love love
um my friend George Campbell just had a
baby this morning are we allowed to
announce it yeah yeah it'll be out there
by the time it's out
yeah uh by the time the show airs and
wow the message I sent him was
everything in your life just changed
because you didn't know he didn't know
and yeah when my buddy's like dude I
think I'm gonna ask this girl to marry
me and then they called and like she
said yes and I would always tell them
everything just changed
love makes you realize the things that
you thought were important ah weren't
that important love helps you sift
through those other relationships and a
few will make it through because they
will be all about loving you and this
new knucklehead you've decided to be
with and if y'all break up in two months
those women who were so excited for you
will be the ones that come over to your
house with nachos in sadness and just
sit with you and light candles and talk
bad about them and sprinkle you with
essential oils and thieves and whatever
like they'll do all that stuff right and
the other girls will say I told you so
yeah that is kind of accurate yeah and
you don't want those women in your life
they're opting out they're opting out
you are good to go you're good to go
Christine I'm proud of you
and I like as I I'm such a sucker for a
love story I love it when people fall in
love so I'm really excited for you
that's fun even if it doesn't work out
long term because you're still basically
a child it's still pretty awesome and
I'm excited for you I do hate it that
your friends are opting out
but
I hate to say this this will be the rest
of your life you'll get a job somewhere
that you're excited about and two people
will opt out and you'll have two kids
and somebody will opt out or you'll
choose to have no kids and people will
opt out
and I think the great challenge of our
life isn't to run around and make sure
everybody is okay that we're making sure
that their world is good at our expense
I think it is sitting in that sadness
and heartbreak when people choose to opt
out of relationship with us
oh because that hurts you're awesome
Christine
uh I'm trying to think of a good 80s
metal song but those all ended pretty
tragically so Go Get It Go Get Married
is there hey Jenna is there is there a
Taylor Swift song about young love
I was gonna say dear John but that was
not a good song right sweet nothing
Sweet Nothing Christine listen to that
song I don't know is that is that good
sure all right we'll be right back